[Music]
live from the Jon Lovitz podcast theater
kids Hollywood babble-on
with your hosts Kevin Smith and Ralph
Garman
[Music]
it is Saturday night in Hollywood so
let's babble the [ __ ] on I'm Kevin Smith
I'm Ralph Garman it's almost Halloween
man tonight it's 7:00 a stroke and I'm
like Batman I like to be prepared for
every eventuality but you haven't a
stroke in the opening of the show I was
never prepared for it by the time we get
to hosting we Dick Clark you go to hell
for that kind of [ __ ] too soon ah it is
it's right it's right before Halloween
Oh switch to the gay ghost what wait
so weird so weird funny you should say
that because I apologize in advance I
was going to come tonight in costume I
know but I ran out of time I was
prepping the show I take all day
Saturday to kind of compile the show and
I take all day Saturday to smoke weed
right those are our jobs preparing for
the show and we've moved the show up to
8 o'clock now we're in primetime so I'm
still off on my time management so I I
got the show prepped and I started to
put together the finishing touches for
the gay ghost costume which was a cheesy
ass store-bought ghost costume with a
mask and like a you know usually like a
sheet basically you know right and I
said well that's the ghost part so then
I was putting together a t-shirt that I
was gonna put over it with the words I
enjoy penis on them so I got the t-shirt
earlier today and I got those iron-on
letters and those [ __ ] don't work
don't buy those iron-on letters I was
ironing the [ __ ] out of those letters
I got 45 minutes of ironing and they
were just falling off they weren't
sticking but I finally got down to I
enjoy and I said that will make any
sense I put on an I enjoy t-shirt over
the ghost that'd be so positive though
man like if I encountered somebody who's
just like I enjoy like I wouldn't be
like I'm not even gonna ask you what
buddy I understand what you mean I enjoy
too but that would be like a Buddhist
ghost it wouldn't be a gay ghost so I
said I can't just go out there those
cheesy ghost costume I can eat the whole
thing you know so anyway I ran out of
time I was like 7:35 I'm ironing it's a
[ __ ] pissed I just grabbed my [ __ ] under
out the door so I apologize but imagine
me looking like a ghost with I enjoy
penis on my chest if you will I'm in
costume as per usual yes you did every
week you come in costume I know we have
some costumes out there tonight too
right now a few folks in costume wow
look at four holy [ __ ] there's an
onomatopoeia up there Wow oh that's
[ __ ] dope for those that don't know
that was a character that I put in green
arrow and in Batman that's [ __ ] up
we'll be doing can company later on
tonight that's so cool look at the
Mighty Thor up there ever seen The
Mighty Thor
yes [ __ ] Thor he wasn't in my book in my
book all right yes very impressive
look at four that's oh [ __ ] yeah now daf
very good yeah and Black Widow next to
him well we got the penguin anywhere oh
[ __ ]
Jesus
that doesn't look like much costume sir
that looks like mostly you nothing
personal but I'll be honest man I
thought it was a mirror suspended from
the ceiling this is [ __ ] amazing
people are dressed up I'm stoned I'm
like it's a penguin it's poor it's your
wettest dreams come true is what it is
well thanks everyone who went to the
effort that I didn't tonight and
actually came in costume real quickly
tonight's show is sponsored we have a
sponsor tonight a brand new sponsor the
Dave School for those of you who are
true geeks you might know what the Dave
school is already because they've had
some amazing videos and films they've
already put out but the Dave School is
the digital animation and visual effects
school and they work out of the back lot
at Universal Studios in Orlando and
they've got a one-year training program
in computer animation and visual effects
so they wanted everyone to know about so
you can go to Dave school.com for more
information if you're looking to get
into the movies or television as a
visual cartoons man would you pick up a
few of them we've we've found some
really great amateur animators
cartoonists that we've put up on our
YouTube channel and see smart fantastic
fantastic stuff so you can go the Dave
school man will high reunion at the wait
to go to school
we'll start throwing you bones Ben as
long as you take audio from one of our
podcasts and make cartoons of us yes so
we can rape your talent and make money
off of you not called rape it's called
exploitation okay
the Dave school people by the way
they're the ones who did that Batman New
Times the Batman Lego Mark Hamill's the
Joker Adam West's Batman Dick Van Dyke
as Commissioner Gordon I love that video
Commissioner Gordon yeah well that sound
like Oh a Mary Poppins I'm Commissioner
Gordon it's a jolly holiday with that
man
I've been selling goin bad I was so into
the music I was about to back you up
alright we want to start off the show as
we do every week by giving some shout
outs to people who've come particularly
long distances or celebrating special
occasions with us here tonight it's a
segment we call appropriately shout out
shout out Kevin Brown so get your [ __ ]
out
yeah we've been on the road for so long
with places that had no wire let's make
that part of the show that's my biggest
contribution to the show without the
wire I couldn't swing a [ __ ] over my
face man and I was like yeah we for some
reason again we get a ton of shout
outside and we apologize that we can't
get to all of you we appreciate your
writing in it
HBO podcast at aol.com but for some
reason we have an inordinate amount of
Australians here this evening river
[ __ ] hey man diplomatic immunity
that's the wrong country is there some
sort of Australia convention in town or
something you guys have a wall of fuss
but is there a koala face all the
Australian gay bears get together in Los
Angeles eat eucalyptus yeah that's what
we call it eucalyptus but maybe there is
a boomerang trade show in town or
something and they're all here so a lot
of Australians here tonight including
Dale from Walla Gong Australia hey Dale
boy oh boy suddenly it's a frat party I
don't know what happened
Dale writes I'm in from Walla Gong
Australia and I'll be attending the show
unfortunately my wife Kathleen couldn't
get time off to join me at the
conference it is qualify right I told
you man and he didn't bring a girl as
you can see yes I recently made her sit
through HBO during some long road trips
she has come to admit that HBO has now
grown on her but still has an issue on
how often Kevin talks about his
masturbation routine getting lying
Kathleen
to be fair I don't think I talked about
it all that much but now that really you
know last night I talked about something
[ __ ] alright and you know anyone can
do it you know it's not a skill we all
we all do it I celebrate myself Ralph
I'm a little miracle my mother told me
that from birth everything that I do and
produce is wonderful so so yeah after I
drop one in my old lady man so you'd
imagine I'd [ __ ] be like I'm done and
[ __ ] but like a teenager I was like I'm
gonna go down in my office crack crack
crack so I don't know what she's talking
about in the letter man the actual sound
your ejaculate makes to crack crack
crack yeah I don't go soft man I'm 42
year old man crack crack crack I gotta
hurry up you know got a wife down the
hallway get downstairs does your penis
have a knuckle what are you cracking no
but there is a ratchet affair Dale
continues Kathleen's favorite depression
of yours is the gay ghost so I would
love to give her a shout-out in that
voice saying that I'm working hard the
whole time and I'm promising that I
won't be giving and receiving any
massages from John Travolta this
would've been so much funnier if I was
dressed as the gay ghost Dale [ __ ] what
well there blew me so weird he asked not
to talk about it but he blew me Brian
Justin and polo are you guys in the
house you [ __ ] kidding me
took the time to write and couldn't show
up Justin polo and Brian calling Justin
polo and Brian one more time you'll take
it why hello I'm bum they're not here
because they asked us to berate their
friend who couldn't show up the falls of
these guys like Alanis Morissette wrote
a song about this guy isn't it ironic
yes good could you shut up could you
please please parade our play wait who's
filing me or him got a point bro had it
been you double tap
could you please berate our friend
Andrew for not showing up as Andrew Dice
Clay these guys coming in the gate
hickory dickory dock these kids could
suck my [ __ ] Oh believe me I was
watching The Daily Show this week I
think it was this weekend John Stewart
also lapsed into Andrew Dice Clay for a
moment I think everybody secretly likes
to do Andrew Dice when you go hardcore
new yorker he just sort of opportunity
michael Danny and Jason are you guys
here that's what I wanted to hear
wow that sounded so [ __ ] like pre
rehearsed and [ __ ]
like you said and they were like one
more time boys with feeling one that's
you think it's like they're doing the
wave we should get a pre-recorded whoo
so when she [ __ ] don't show up we can
just play it'll sound like they're here
okay that the weakest whoo that'll be
our that'll be our go to whoo all right
one more time Jason it's like [ __ ] I got
$75 back on my tax return you know like
a celebration but not too hard for it's
an orderly celebration
I dropped a Twinkie but I hit my knee
before the floor so I gets deleted
it's a well-mannered celebration
appropriately celebration Jason writes
up in listening to the podcast since
episode one and always wanted to attend
one of your live shows sure certainly
after you shortly after you started the
podcast I was injured at work and needed
to have a cervical spine fusion done to
release the pressure from my to cervical
discs bulging in my spinal cord after
surgery I was in a neck brace for three
months the only exercise oh hold on man
[ __ ] no sad Hulk music on this yet
these two don't go together man we got
to bring the whoo way down way down
ready on the
three yeah like that one two three sad
Hulk woo
sad old get up after the surgery I was
in a neck brace for three months the
only exercise my surgeon has allowed
over the past year and a half is to go
on walks the two of you became my
Hollywood helpers and were and still are
with me on many of my walks I can't
thank you enough for all the laughs
during a very difficult time in my life
happy to be here tonight with my friends
Michael and Danny now give that penis a
sandwich glad you're feeling better
Jason that you can muster a wound with
that whole neck thing and don't feel too
bad man I didn't even have anything like
that happen to me and walking is the
most exercise I've done all year as well
yeah you a mirror-like and not a lot of
it I'm just saying I don't see you
walking a lot [ __ ] you Ralph
sorry I press the wrong button now let's
try that again
[ __ ] you Ralph they're so close together
that's the problem down we better labels
ah yeah really
Daniel Cynthia Danny and jenni welcome
guys coming to the show this weekend to
celebrate my 30th birthday Daniel writes
I'm bringing along my sister Cynthia my
brother-in-law Danny and my cousin Jenny
my original plan was to celebrate my
28th birthday at the old Smaug castle
but unfortunately I was unable to attend
I had a hemorrhagic stroke three weeks
before where's this [ __ ] Lourdes what
healing is sick here oh love that man
appropriate level whoo we're the rock
Brotherhood whoo for that joke we should
be faith healers remain our healing is
sick with this show legs up humble
[ __ ] cripples and humpbacks I had a
hemorrhagic stroke three weeks before I
spent ten days in a coma and when I came
to Daniel writes I was unable to move my
right side they told me I would never
walk again that was the day I committed
myself to walking again who are these
brave [ __ ] people man because they're
right over there
yes hello if the doctor said to me give
it up for the man
this [ __ ] will walk with anybody
you're the loneliest Walker I've ever
met before the friendliest Ralph if a
doctor told me you're never gonna walk
again I would immediately be like right
on turn the TV on
that'd be the greatest news you bring me
a tray of peanut butter jelly sandwiches
man just keep putting them in my mouth
anyway Daniel writes I committed myself
to walking again I told myself that one
day I would walk in to see this podcast
today is that day welcome Daniel that's
awesome I would love to hear a pep talk
from Sean Connery really you couldn't
have picked a more sympathetic character
of mine to give you a pep talk he's very
motivational yes he is your right side
is [ __ ] lazy it's about time your
[ __ ] right side got off its ass and
started walking again your left side was
dancing a [ __ ] jig and your right
side was boring finally your right side
woke up I hope your left side kicks its
ass later tonight [ __ ] right side
there you go there's your pep talk from
Sean Connery
Congrats man Congrats
that's one of those stories I taught
they said I wouldn't walk I said [ __ ]
them I will walk someday and then he
proves them wrong and walks and says
walking into here was his motivation yes
you need more to your life sir to use
this as your motivation but maybe you're
going to walk into a small comedy club
someday near a big theme park and gonna
I'm gonna buy a drink listen to a drunk
and a stoned guy tell ass [ __ ] jokes
so there doc you can't keep me down the
wrong way my life son this is like a
third act in a [ __ ] TV movie man
[ __ ] shows up here at the club
under his own steam walks in and listens
to you tell a joke credits that's
[ __ ] amazing unless it's the second
act and a [ __ ] horror movie and then
the third act [ __ ] goes wrong in which
case let's enjoy the [ __ ] second act
while we're here man like maybe there's
a third the third act villain like Loki
or something like that with the pokey
stick what strain you smoking tonight oh
gee Chemex it's called
OG Chemex yeah it's got on the label a
little picture of Bunsen honeydew and
beaker it does it does it say do not up
operate microphones while under the use
of this medicine is weed so good you
feel like you got a hand up your ass
Muppet weed how about how about a recent
nest from Australia you guys here am I
saying that properly Rhys that was
confuses me that's that [ __ ] spelling
rhy is that Rhys you know the Brits and
the Australians use that I don't whether
it's rice Rhys refuse I don't know what
it is
it's Rhys it's rice its race you to want
to duke it out you want to settle this
after the show ness writes we flew in
from Sydney this morning wow that's a
long flight you must be exhausted
you're in drunk well you're Australian
that goes without saying madam this was
a surprise to my wonderful husband for
our second wedding anniversary early
birthday present what you just threw him
on the plane he didn't know where he was
going
that's called kidnapping in this country
thanks to your love of anal I've had to
explain to my mom what a rusty wagon
wheel is rights nests followed by her
response did you know that there's a
drug to loosen your butthole and then my
mom typing gay man's drug to loosen your
butthole into Google the coolest mom in
the world
what is that drug stop it is there
really a drug I think there is what is
it called Spanish Fly so called poppers
that's it poppers is it's it's basically
head cleaner for a VCR there no gay men
in the audience for God's sakes never
poppers I've heard of them but a little
bottle and originally it was a head
cleaner for VCR back in the days when we
used to use VCRs I think DJ James
fingers will loose right now but they
found if you sniffed it yeah
you don't actually snort the liquid you
sniff the fumes it cuts off the
circulation to your brain it replaces
oxygen in your brain and it makes you
[ __ ] high
and apparently loosens your [ __ ] for
how long does it make you high and for
how long does it loosen your [ __ ]
it wears off very quickly your high for
I don't know 30 I'll get the [ __ ] out on
that one right but it loosens your
[ __ ] for about five years
no you just walk around just [ __ ]
falling out of you everywhere
Ralph could you please welcome Rhys in
your Edwin voice and wish him a happy
anniversary and apologize for the lack
of anal wait a minute there's poppers
why aren't you given a piano someone get
her some poppers so he can have her ass
look at how adorable she's like now now
now he won't go waltzing matilda back
there i don't take it at the didgeridoo
[Laughter]
nests ads when your [ __ ] this tight
you don't need to use the death tunnel
death tunnel what the [ __ ] you have
hidden up there razor blades it sounds
like a Saw movie I would imagine that's
what someone who doesn't want to want a
no calls it like yeah you can put it up
my death tunnel if you want but then I
do it to you next
[ __ ] me there I will kill you that's why
it's called the death tunnel thanks for
the laughs education and awkward
positions you've put me in for the past
two years Ness alright Edwin - Therese -
welcome him to the show oh my goodness
here's what you do get your wife some
poppers and you stick them up her nose
and they say this is for put me on a
plane [ __ ] kidnapped the man little
harsh punishment don't you think
especially something rise - until the
crime Sall from London saw you here all
the way from London where are you
brother yeah back in the country for
humans since now I live in London doing
all the touristy things I decided to see
the musical The Book of Mormon yeah it's
amazing if you haven't seen it go see it
don't [ __ ] the baby unfortunately I
couldn't get Kevin's stupid little boys
out of my head singing don't [ __ ] the
baby the whole [ __ ] show
you should really let me Bree read this
[ __ ] man no way you're the greatest
straight man in the business I'd really
appreciate Kevin telling me what else to
do in Los Angeles in his creepy sexy
boys Oh Kevin Oh what's his name Saul
Saul you want to go to a place called
Marik's on Santa Monica Boulevard just
off it man it's right off the corner
it's behind a place called basics
it is a Mexican restaurant that it
really it's a restaurant recommendation
that's what you're giving them yeah what
else they serve nachos that is sexy big
girl also has if I might jump out of the
sexy voice the best [ __ ] music of any
place you'd go in Los Angeles man well
it's pretty gay down there I love it
it's fantastic go in there talk to you I
feel comfortable at a coincidence it's
not a coincidence crowd but I take my
kid there it's fantastic the only place
you could take Y she's 13 year old girls
starting to develop and [ __ ] like that
everyone's a lot of people look at me
like oh he's traded up and got a younger
wife you know I'm like this is my
[ __ ] kid but why not you go to eat
there man ain't nobody looking at the
kid they're all looking at me
oh I said I'm just like I always [ __ ]
like oh can you pass me the menu it's
the only place that I can pull that like
here's the ticket to the gun show where
I get a few friends very bare friend but
it's also a great restaurant and they a
fantastic case so and blackened chicken
tacos anyway that's what I would do if I
was here from London imagine all that in
a sexy voice and lastly Amanda Holman
Amanda you here
where's Amanda upstairs second second
row hello Amanda
huge fan have been for years I was
devastated when you got married Ralph
wow man trust me so was my wife two
years ago I took my brother to see HBO
for his birthday and we loved it we're
coming again for his birthday his name
is Jason but for years we've just called
each other stupid I'd be thrilled if
David Bowie could sing happy birthday to
my brother's stupid
thanks so much can't wait to see you
again gar me strong Amanda well that
with so much love between the two of you
how could I resist this request coming a
little bit unchanged
happy birthday to you stupid happy
birthday to you stupid stupid you're
such a [ __ ] idiot happy birthday to
you stupid happy birthday
happy but they're from your system she's
the one that calls you stupid happy
pretend to be stupid happy birthday to
it you're [ __ ] stupid happy birthday
and did you just wipe your imaginary
jism on me it's cool or friends man my
babies are all over you imaginary jism
by the way would be a great band name we
got to start a band where's the drama we
are imaginary jism good night imaginary
jism gets all over you
we also read out loud emails that we get
from all around the world
[Music]
featuring Kevin's reactions this first
email starts Ralph and CEM I found this
list while presume perusing I found this
this while perusing IMDB guys familiar
with IMDB the use of the know Ralph
because we all just got here from 1989
some people may not like there's like
three tentpoles on the Internet [ __ ]
Google Amazon and the IMDB at least in
my house
well sure cuz you're in the business but
some people may not know it's where you
go to look up movie people in their
history and stuff like that
ons way boy is a magazine with naked
lady stop it the one time I try to be
[ __ ] nice and helpful and you're
gonna give me [ __ ] about it fine go on I
found a list on there called enemies of
modern movies and I thought you might
like it thanks again for the free funny
and again if you need an army base in
Dallas
I'll bring the jack in the buds see sans
from Dallas writes this list so I took a
look at this list it is very interesting
it's the 15 according to Yahoo seven
seven seven seven
the guy who put the list together these
are enemies of modern movies people who
always look for the bad stuff in modern
movies persons who don't know the
meaning of the word entertainment is the
list on the list of the top 15 Leonard
Maltin is 15th on the list Peter Travers
of Rolling Stone the movie critic for
that magazine is 12th Ben Lyons is ninth
Jay Leno is eighth I thought was strange
about everybody
maybe cuz he makes jokes or something
like maybe he counts but I've never seen
a bad mouth anyone anybody's movie when
they got him on the show it was great
[ __ ] a Jay Leno
[Music]
he's a good such a [ __ ] such a
marshmallow I hear when I watch that
show
whoahhh Matt Stone and Trey Parker or
seven and six Seth MacFarlane they make
fun of movies on the show yeah Seth
MacFarlane was fit does he makes fun of
movies yep Richard Roeper the critic
forth Roger Ebert was second can we
throw up number one in the list can we
put it on the big screen soon the number
one number one enemy of modern movies
according to this guy Yahoo 77077 is
Ralph Garman are you [ __ ] kidding me
I'm number one I'm public enemy number
one when it comes to movies [ __ ] me
you gotta call your parents this is huge
dude you beat out some [ __ ] number
one ever so I guess I should enjoy it
but this guy really seriously I'm number
I'm the enemy of modern movies I would
agree how dare you sir I was chagrined
by that but kind of thrilled secretly
the next email comes from Matt in
Australia I'm from down under
I listen religiously I have no job no
girlfriend and live at home with my
parents boy apparently the same [ __ ]
happens in Australia happens in America
I'm hoping you can keep the noose I have
made hidden away by giving me a shout
out on my birthday this weekend someone
thought that was hilarious these guys
comply contemplating suicide
be an Australian thing much-loved format
in Australia could Kevin please wish me
happy birthday I know he does a terrible
Aussie accent so maybe he can wish me
the birthday the size of a tangerine in
his Alfred the butler voice that is how
whenever I'm hanging out with Scott
Mosier in order to get to the Michael
Caine impression we always go to the
line from The Dark Knight where he goes
the size of a tangerine so whenever we
try to go to an Australian accent we go
there and then people always like he's
not Australian Hockney I know but for
some reason that helps us get into it
well can you wish Matt a happy birthday
birthday the size of a tangerine for him
yes is he here no no he's not this is an
email okay everyone else is following
along with the show excellent point
coming from the guy that just had to
[ __ ] try to explain the internet this
is for you Matt once Shelley swagman
what's the [ __ ] rest of the words we
got some [ __ ] Australians here what
is it thank you camped by a Billabong
under the shade of a hula bar tree help
me out and he sang and he sat and he
sang as he watched his bill of oil won't
you go waltzing matilda with me help me
out now everyone jeez just sing along
you go Waltzing Matilda Waltzing Matilda
won't you go waltzing matilda with me so
Matt's not here and he shouldn't get
this really cool song but you made me so
now we are done there we go
[Applause]
not to be picky but he did ask for a
birthday the size of a tangerine in your
Alfred birthday the size of a tangerine
there you go
thank you so much charlie Kyle Berg
writes in from New York City
t-shirt he'll calm as a new t-shirt I
think you guys should offer there where
you do your show I thought I'd share the
shirt with you and he did he sent in a
picture of this brand new t-shirt is
available on t-shirt he'll calm they're
familiar with the I Love New York logo
the I heart New York I Love New York
this is another option they have on
their this is I love it's New York
versus I Love New York picture our buddy
Jon Lovitz with a big red face right
that's a door we should sell those here
quick story about the I heart New York I
probably told it before about say it
again in clerks too we had somebody in
the dance scene wearing t-shirts at I
heart NJ we got sued by the state of New
York who has trademark and copyrighted I
heart anything yeah yeah yeah so we had
to pay a little bit of money after the
fact and [ __ ] either that or digitally
remove it from the movie Wow
and I [ __ ] that we also had inside I
think there was an I heart movies or
something like that we had to digitally
work with that you should have got a new
t-shirt to be worn in that scene and
it's just said I [ __ ] New York and
should have a big finger big middle
finger on the t-shirt that they haven't
trademarked that this one too long after
you know the tragic period of September
11 oh alright they get a pass there I
didn't want to get into it with him
right about all right you get a pass
soon
Brandon Arnold writes several weeks ago
I introduced my girlfriend Ashley to
Hollywood babble-on she immediately fell
in love with your wonderful podcast
she's an idiot
we have not missed an episode since she
has started listening and now I'm not
even allowed to listen to an episode
without her not the nice cute now that I
mind much because she is the Rachel
Dawes to my Batman the Katie Holmes one
very she says not Maggie Gyllenhaal
because who would want to [ __ ] that he's
got a point
boyfriend a girlfriend here these two
I'm just saying in real life Oh Maggie
Joann husband yeah yeah yeah an actor
yeah yeah visions not good married to
Stevie Wonder I think's good a lot of
[ __ ] quiet hostility in this room
suddenly from the back he's like you've
been waiting to say that for three years
man
Brandon Arnold here ads have Ashley were
to die I would become a bum for eight
years in practice archery in my bedroom
it's a Batman thing anyway the only
person actually loves more than me is
Adam West so it'd be awesome if you
Ralph as Adam West could ask Ashley to
marry me so she will hear this as we
listen together the [ __ ] out of here
really do you think this is for reals I
do get the sense it's for real all right
man [ __ ] handle it gently Ashley are
you [ __ ] [ __ ] me you're winging
you're gonna wing this you knew there
was a [ __ ] engagement is that you
were you had to set up and you're like
[ __ ] it I'll wing it and [ __ ] you should
have written some [ __ ] down man do you
want to take 10 minutes I'll take over
for the show you go right so this is
these people are tying their lives
together and you're just gonna be like
hello old chum
[Applause]
I'm sorry can I hear your head please
hold the phone can I hear your Adam
Watson I feel like I've gone too far or
Bea Arthur listen this is how I feel
about this this guy wrote into a podcast
to preserve a man would just sit his
girl down and say will you marry me he's
asking a podcast to do his work for him
broadcasting legend he gets what he gets
Ashley your boyfriend Brandon would love
to have your hand in marriage
personally I think it's too soon perhaps
you two would like to take some time
apart date some other people let's see
if you're really meant for each other if
you love something let it go if it comes
back then you slide down the batpoles of
matrimony together otherwise [ __ ] off do
I get that work
well done dang it and this gentleman did
not leave his name if they're gonna
write an email they you should identify
yourself but I did appreciate this email
he sent and I hope Ralph is getting
royalty checks for his likeness being
used by these Halloween dolls I saw in
the store this week they looked just
like him can we throw up the picture of
the the holiday it's supposed to be a
vampire of some kind and yet it does
look eerily like me you grow a little
leather jacket on it man blue and lastly
this email right dear Ralph and Kevin
from slacks 86 is his name I'm guessing
that's not a sexual name but that's how
we signed this slack see that's what I
say whenever I go into a men's store can
I get some slacks 86 the only way I can
think of truly celebrating Halloween is
by having Harrison Ford sing the Monster
Mash once again we're gonna add this to
my album ralph sings the hits and
various voices y'all singing acapella
this is the Harrison Ford scene the
Halloween classic the Monster Mash
I didn't know it wasn't gravy it's magic
they didn't to mine he caught all on the
phone they did the bag there you go
alright we got another email here but
it's asking for a creepy clown voice so
that means it's creepy clown time there
we go we had to request tonight
now I thought we had done one before so
I gave it a backup but I'll let the
crowd decide because this guy asks I was
listening to the Las Vegas show and I
was wondering what a John Travolta gay
ghost creepy clown might sound like we
did that before didn't we but it was
Halloween so I thought that was sort of
appropriate now the other one from Alan
in Tennessee
rights simply Bowie clown Bowie clown
Bowie clown so I can redo gay ghost
clown or I can do a brand new one Bowie
clown we've never done but I would scare
me
[Music]
there you go boa class every week we
like to say goodbye to some folks who
have passed away who are no longer with
us who deserve a shout-out and this week
is no exception
they're called the Tinseltown steps and
now another edition of
they will be missed this week Russell
Means passed away at the age of 72 for
those who don't know Russell Means was
an American Indian rights activist he
was one of the leaders of the Wounded
Knee occupation remember that story
there were there were a group of
American Native Americans who took over
Wounded Knee South Dakota in his 71 day
armed occupation demanding rights for
Native Americans and it was a big deal
he was an outspoken champion for
American Indian rights and then he
launched a career as an actor in films
and television in the 80s and 90s he
appeared in such films as the Last of
the Mohicans naturally what he was an
Indian I can say that I'm like 1/8
chocolate ah is that true nope he was in
Natural Born Killers ok and he was the
voice of Pahang
in Disney's animated film Pocahontas
passed away at the age of 71 this week
he was by all accounts a great leader
for his people and did a lot to help
Native American rights and a really good
actor too I remember him in last
Mohicans he was really good big big
Papoose full of whims yes
may may the may the sacred Buffalo guide
you across the native plains of the
after world and take you to the big DB
in the sky
all I got man I think it's like
mainstream religions caught on more
because the prayers are shorter and
easier to remember
yes that was a really long one so I made
up on the spot there's an Indian theme
in tonight's show because we've got a
Hollywood helper tonight that also has
to do with the Native Americans
you're rolling your eyes at the
Hollywood help are already not rolling
my eyes it's just it's very nice but
it's awfully it's time to awfully well
though Johnny Depp who is actually part
Cherokees got a piece in Amelia
he donated this week $25,000 to the
Navajo Nation for college scholarships
fantastic so that more kids can go from
the reservation go to get the Advanced
Learning and go away go on to kata is
actually really really cool $25,000 is a
monetary gift given to the Navajo Nation
and will be set aside used for
scholarships for Navajo children who
want to go to college $25,000 which I
believe is what Johnny Depp pays for
shoes
I'm just saying brothers got a lot of
money
a lot of wampum no I'm saying
mmm you make many millions for pirates
Caribbean and he gives 25k to the
Navajos I don't get it are you saying
he's a Hollywood helper you're not
saying the Hollywood Hollywood no it's
more like this he's a Hollywood help her
yeah that's the appropriate level yeah
25 I appreciate the gesture I'm just
saying Johnny if I buys a bottle of wine
with dinner that cost 25k that's what
I'm guessing on the reservation or
something like that maybe that means for
one person yeah be sending one kid to
college you will end up being gutted EPs
personal assistant at some point I'm
sure it could be his young Ward his
Robin its Lone Ranger and Tonto you're
mixing up your duo's that's true every
week we look at something that happens
in movies that simply should not be in
fact we call it [ __ ] that should not be
[Music]
see here's some [ __ ] that should not the
[ __ ] that should not be this week comes
from the movie Dick Tracy
you guys remember Dick Tracy it's coming
out on blu-ray beautiful movie yep Tracy
before he dicks you I used to say I
don't know why I would say that but I
used to say that quite and then other
people would say avoid that man Warren
Beatty stars as a legendary comic strip
detective Dick Tracy which he wouldn't
put on the nose was the only weird right
because you know that promise get a big
honkin hilarious profile the nose kind
of comes out like this but he everyone
else wore makeup and [ __ ] like that to
make him look like the characters from
the comic strips but all he would do is
put on the outfit he wouldn't be that
bright lemon yellow hat and trench coat
and stuff there is here at Hollywood
babble-on we think that there are many
scenes in films that remarkably get
through all of the hundreds of people
have to look at a film before it gets
released and [ __ ] slips through the
cracks and this is one of those things I
always find it difficult to watch people
genuinely getting hurt on film even if
it's even if it's a stuntman for example
I think it's inappropriate to use that
footage if someone genuinely gets hurt
remember we did Dale what's his dad a
cemetery he rolls out of bed and I've
seen his smashes his head on the
nightstand he's like he's all [ __ ] up
and they kept it in the film it's like
that's inappropriate
Warren Beatty stuntmen a Dick Tracy gets
a face full of lamppost in the film I
don't know if I've ever seen this enough
but we brought the clip and I never
noticed it before but mal from Kirkcaldy
Scotland sent it in and said this is
wildly appropriate [ __ ] that should not
be and I think he's got a point
I brought the scene in for ya we're
gonna show you the scene and we'll slow
it down right afterwards watch the head
of Warren Beatty stunt man as he leaps
from the ledge of a building onto a
streetlight below
[Music]
right here watch this
Oh
however he held on to the streetlamp but
every stunt person man I've ever worked
with it they get remotely hurt they're
always like used that one man that's
what I'm here for so no doubt that dude
was like please use that take this I
guarantee you he didn't say that he said
my [ __ ] job which translates to why
didn't you wear the [ __ ] nose if he
had worn the nose he might have hit the
nose that's right we got some padding
instead of snapping his head back every
week we also look at some a-list actors
who turn in less than a level
performances in a segment we call
exquisite acting welcome to the world of
exquisite acting with Ralph Garman
exquisite acting this week it is
Halloween week all the parties are
tonight the big Halloween parties
Halloween's coming up but was a Tuesday
I think of this week so it's only
appropriate we look to a horror film for
this week's exquisite acting it's Friday
the 13th part 4 oh that's the good one
every other one is really good Friday
the 13th part 4 stars a desperately on
Crispin Glover and this email reads I
thought this might work for some
exquisite acting I thought it was
impossible for anyone to dance worse
than John funk jean-claude Van Damme
when he was an extra in kickboxer but
Crispin Glover went and did it in Friday
the 13th part 4 please enjoy this is
from Matt Burton in London England in
the film
Crispin Glover shockingly is cast as a
nerd in the film and he's tried
desperately to come on to this girl at
this house party before they all start
getting mercilessly slaughtered and he
wants to dance with her so he puts on
inappropriately fast dance music and
then I guess the director said we'll
just dance like a nerd Crispin Glover
took that and abused the privilege here
here's your scene from Frye the 13th
part 4 with Crispin Glover and some
exquisite acting
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
because you're embarrassing yourself
that's why we turned it off hideous I
like him though man he's always
interesting he's always like if the
cameras on I'm gonna try to do something
weird I can kick my new favorites not
new anymore my favorite game on the hill
we play here on the show is called keV
in where we take pictures of Kevin and
drop him into wildly inappropriate
situations where Kevin would never be
you people are very good at some
Photoshop I gotta tell you let's take it
this take a look at this week's keV
[Music]
what's Kevin this week let's take a look
Monday night of course was the final
Demick Democratic and Republican debate
between our two candidates for US
president I did not all see I watched I
think you did more than tune in I should
have watched because let's take a look
at the photo there I had no idea I had
no idea that you participated had I know
and I would have watched you should have
told me and by the way I'm writing you
in for president because I very
impressed you I'm trying to locate
looking at Barack like oh you silly
black man you know ever there was a year
I might be able to get elected this
would be a dead heat you could be the
tiebreaker it's crazy and that all came
from the first debate remember back at
the first debate the president was ahead
by a large margin yeah we said on the
show there's no way that brock can lose
his election it did I mean he didn't yet
but I mean he let the dude catch up with
that first [ __ ] debate so crazy that
was from Andrew H Allen from Sydney
Australia wrote I figured I'd do a keV
in where I made Kevin's boyhood dream
come true but this was this was kind of
cool
carrying the cop on the ice as if you
did not my boyhood dream though that's
my adult dream my boyhood dream would
have been me inside Carrie Fisher
luckily for all of us we don't have a
photo of that tonight and lastly from
Wesley at 10:00 from London England he
wrote in I sent in a Kevin featuring
Kevin's greatest fear and his greatest
movie Jaws because we know how you feel
about sharks and I looked at this
picture and I said I said I see this
looks like just the poster to me I don't
get it where's Kevin can we zoom in
maybe on this like there we go that's
the section we're looking for for the
record I don't know it looks awfully
sexy it's not there's a picture of me I
people keep sending me the picture of
the like is this you
I was wondering because you look pretty
sexy no no no I wish believe me that's
the sad thing I look at the picture all
the time I'm like I wish I was that cut
it's it's a big beefy hairy dude with
his arms kind of over his head posing
very or erotic Lee yes apparently the
Photoshop is so good even my wife came
into my office one day and was like is
this you can we do this well it's time
to take a look at this week's showbiz
headlines with a segment we call HBO
headlines
[Music]
this week's entertainment news headlines
Bowie in a good batch this week Justin
Bieber's all over the news this week all
over the news why he throwing up again I
did not throw up this week but things
got even worse for a Justin because
people are just [ __ ] with him now and
I for one I'm all for that I don't know
if you saw it late this week somebody
somebody genius went on Twitter and
dummied up a tweet that looked like it
was from the official Entertainment
Tonight Twitter feed this is what they
put up there can we throw that up pop
star Justin Bieber was diagnosed with
cancer earlier this morning Bieber fans
are shaving their heads to show their
support the hashtag bald for Bieber
quickly caught fire on Twitter oh God
now there has been no official no
official documentation of any
prepubescent girl shaving her head to
support Justin Bieber however we just
have to [ __ ] hope people we just have
to hope just just just please God just
one of them do it just one if one little
girl shaves her head and goes into work
the next morning well I saw some photos
but look like there was Photoshop saying
bald for B but really one of your
friends did it was it a girl oh that's
awesome that somebody actually did it so
Paul for Bieber became a thing before
the hoax was exposed apparently there
were have been rumors that some people
actually did it I'm glad to hear sir
thank you for confirming that some
Bieber fan actually shaved their head is
it a 4chan it was a 4chan stun yeah god
bless them for the good work that they
do
weird wonderful stuff yes
that's kind of horrible but it's kind of
funny cuz it's Justin Bieber yeah I mean
I blow is it horrible I mean it's kind
of if you shaved your head then the next
morning found out but the whole thing
was well you've learned a very important
lesson yeah and there's nothing wrong
with that no there's not
Justin also had a hard week because nude
photos of his dad are being shopped
around apparently apparently when Jeremy
Bieber was younger he posed for an
all-nude erotic mail full frontal photo
shoot I was Selena Gomez too by the way
all the girls from eighth grade are here
tonight man yeah actually Jeremy Bieber
is pretty good-looking guy I've ever
seen yeah I've seen picture he's got a
Billy Ray Cyrus kind of vibe to him he
actually looks like he can kick all of
our asses so we should be careful yeah
they look like they were taken for a
Playgirl type magazine or something says
the source that was trying to sell the
photos what you're from they say younger
days so I'm guessing before Bieber pre
Bieber no probably I got the the gist of
the story was probably about ten years
ago it sounded like I mean the guy's not
old I don't know maybe he's early
forties so apparently it was when he was
in his prime we're not there yet sir and
there is apparently some sort of bidding
war going on the internet for someone to
publish the photos what someone really
be interested in nude photos of Justin
Bieber's dad Oh commander like see where
Justin Bieber used to live see these
balls that used to be his home totally
man and my favorite story of the week
we're getting out of the way early it's
another Bieber story a man from Michigan
has filed a lawsuit against Justin
Bieber this guy is [ __ ] insane but
the lawsuit is hysterical the man from
Michigan whose name has not been
disclosed by the press filed a lawsuit
in Michigan this week saying that he was
secretly what's his name what's the name
of the girlfriend he's going out with
Selena Gomez Lena Gomez his dad and the
lawsuit reads as follows Justin Bieber
cost me four hundred and twenty six
point seven eight dollars and never paid
me back this money was used as abortion
money because Justin Bieber got my
daughter Selena pregnant in my bedroom
on my Canadian bear rug is a legal
document rocks god Bless America of
course it's a Canadian bear rug because
that's the sexiest kind and very
important it continues he's also suing
uh sure because and I quote uh sure came
to my house on the 4th of July 2012 and
sodomized me with a firework he lit it
inside my anal area inside my anal area
this guy wrote his own document as you
can tell while blaring Katy Perry's
Firework song in my ears oh my god like
I admit that got me a little hard when I
heard that that's kind of sexy he
continues with his lawsuit Justin Bieber
gave Selena an STD and then Bieber stole
my credit card to buy himself and Sean P
Diddy Combs cocaine to use in drug free
school zones and lastly Justin Bieber
also got a penis enlargement with my
stolen American Express card
he also alleges that Justin's been
cheating on Selena Gomez with Ke$ha
Rihanna and Penelope Cruz I wonder if we
can all jump in on this make it a
class-action lawsuit I would like to as
well I hope this week was a big story a
reality show host Donald Trump was in
the news he promised a bombshell that
would bust Obama campaign wide open have
you heard this or not when it finally
was announced it turned out to be more
of an offer than a bombshell he said
he'll give 5 million dollars to the
charity the president's choice if Obama
would release his application
information for his college and his
passport that's not ill wants to that's
not news see if he's a born here or
something like that I think that goes
back to the birther [ __ ] he wants to go
back to see whether he's Kenyan or not
basically people immediately mocked and
derailed this this opera by Donald Trump
including many people on the right
but none better in my opinion than
Stephen Colbert on the Cobell report we
don't do this a lot here where we play
other people's comedy bits but this was
so spectacular I thought it was worth
watching here is Stephen Colbert from
his show that night after Trump made his
offer of five million dollars for the
release of that information and Colbert
makes Donald Trump a counteroffer yeah
mr. Trump I will write you a check for 1
million dollars from Colbert super PAC
you know I've got it to the charity of
your choice
anything save the children feed the
children put the children on child
apprentice whatever if you will let me
dip my balls in your mouth no word yet
from Donald Trump's office as to whether
he will accept that offer or not [ __ ] a
good businessman a smart businessman he
might take a man absolutely Mike more
politics and show business crossing
paths this weekend if you saw it or not
but legendary singer meatloaf was
campaigning for Mitt Romney this week
there was a Mitt Romney rally held in
Defiance Ohio that's a place it was
Thursday and meat loaf was there along
with the big and rich the country stars
and the lead singer for Alabama it was
just a redneck paradise is what it was
and meat loaf was there and they joined
Romney on stage at the end of the rally
and everybody was singing America the
Beautiful and I brought in some audio
and video of meatloaf singing America
the Beautiful only because this [ __ ]
sings for a living that's what you need
to remember as you watch the performance
of meatloaf singing America the
Beautiful
[Music]
he's gonna join in a minute
[Music]
[Applause]
as if chris farley came back to life
guy used to have hit records let's just
all take a moment his name was Robert
Paulson thank you I will do anything for
love but I won't sing on key the new
lyric more politics and celebrity
crossing paths this week Tila Tequila
this week declared war on the Illuminati
that's right you [ __ ] Illuminati you
better run for those of you don't know
and maybe everyone does maybe it's like
IMDB but the Illuminati is the secret
shadow government that is running things
throughout the world they are the
super-rich the super powerful they are
the the puppet masters who are making
all of the world's economies work
x-files parlance they are the cigarette
smoking man that's right Tila Tequila
declared war on them this week in a
rambling pages long open letter to the
Illuminati which just it's just I've got
it all here and I'm gonna read it all no
I'm kidding I'm gonna read you some
highlights here's what tequila said this
week we're all sick and tired of your
[ __ ] you want a war okay let's get ready
for one but only if you precipitate
yourself and not act like a bunch of old
ugly rich evil cowards it is on people I
declare war but no soldiers just me the
people and all of you so called
Illuminati elitist cowards I have all
your secrets Mike Tila army and the
world at large has you way outnumbered
there's a deal army gar me take arms
tomorrow we battle the Tila army she
went on to say yes sure we all know
about your underground bunkers what we
do old news but shall I tell the people
about of the entire city inside the
Hollow Earth ha Tila Tequila I want to
hear about the city and Hollow where
shall I tell people that you came here
and left your own planet to infiltrate
ours and now some of you currently
reside on the moon
is she picking on the [ __ ]
Scientologists shall I tell them that
the so-called moon is actually where
some of you still reside to watch over
us and the moon is actually your secret
base it sounds like Moonraker man it's
actually we like it so much better when
you're just a std riddled [ __ ] we did
like it better didn't know she was that
she was more fascinating news the father
and mother of Jessica and Ashley Simpson
this week have announced they're
splitting up this is [ __ ] up
keep going are you upset because The
Simpsons are splitting
I'm not upset but this story caught my
attention today and I fell down the
rabbit hole reason I wonder why it's so
bizarre Joe Simpson the manager of
Jessica and Ashley have he is called
quits his marriage with his wife Tina
after 34 years of wedded bliss
sad sad when a relationship falls apart
Ralph especially after that many years
decades together the kids are grown
they're on their own
fair enough so they could maybe they are
ready to take a chance again go forward
have separate relationships in Texas
they filed paperwork said the reason for
the split was discord or conflict of
personalities sometimes that happens
people just can't get along or Alf you
know it's not big deal sometimes
personalities conflict and that's it and
I hear he's got a separate way yeah a
more significant reason may be that Joe
Simpson is actually gay how could that
be Ralph he's been married to a woman
for 34 years
the former Baptist minister explains a
few things
reportedly brought his family together a
few months ago and officially came out
of the closet to them and the split by
all accounts is amicable between himself
and Tina and they're going their
separate ways now I do not know if this
is true or not this is largely
speculation part of the media however
this week Joe Simpson was seen walking
down the street and up
ulis canary yellow sweater with matching
shoes and he had highlights in his hair
and he looked happier than I've ever
seen the weirdest part of the story that
I read about was the dude that he's
potentially hooked up with and seeing is
the 21 year old dude who was a dancer
not for Jessica Simpson but for Britney
Spears
ya know weird you know what this makes
me feel good about though it's Joe
Simpson for years was talking about how
hot his daughter was and how nice her
boobs were he would talk about his wife
Jess is his daughter Jessica Simpson
saying her boobs are just fantastic
aren't they and I would say all that's
so creepy but now that I know that he
wasn't really attracted to boobs it
makes it much better Peter more
observational Bobby Brown got in trouble
this week oh I did that for you Bobby
Brown was nabbed for drunk driving again
this week he was pulled over and booked
on a DUI it was Bobby's second bust for
DUI this year back in March he pled no
contest and checked himself into rehab
but apparently didn't stick because he
was pulled over after drinking and
driving yet again
[Music]
while we're talking about shitty drivers
[Applause]
[Music]
good news for Lindsay this week the
Manhattan da let her off the hook for
those hit-and-run charges outside that
hotel remember when she supposedly ran
into that guy when she was pulling into
the hotel parking lot they looked at the
security footage and they said it was
not proof positive that she in fact
tagged that guy in the knee and so they
are letting her off the hook there no
child no charges will be filed she's
free to go right on man good for ya just
the minute she gets out of her own
[ __ ] way
the Lohan giveth Lohan taketh away this
week it was announced that apparently
she helped herself to a new wardrobe
thanks to the people at scary movie 5
where she was filming that show closes
sources close to the set say she stole
$15,000 worth of clothing from the set I
mean is she 27 yeah why was something
foretold in the Bible when the
fire-crotch become of 27 the earth shall
split open Baptist minister shall turn
gay and suck at the [ __ ] and the nude
Biba father shall be appearing when will
this happen father when the big hand
passes the Lohan
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you that was good that was good
that was just it's like an 80/20 yeah if
you're split it's not a pile to go
[ __ ] show you know battled out in the
parking lot thank you for the whoo that
was like a Frasier joke yeah
Oh for god sakes Niles she was on the
set of scary movie 5 her careers on the
upswing and she helped herself to
$15,000 worth of wardrobe put it in her
trunk and drove up the set apparently
that's what happened so weird I I don't
I think I have maybe four hundred
dollars worth of wardrobe I can't
imagine what $15,000 looks like wouldn't
somebody notice that like they just got
a [ __ ] ton of clothes disappear
producers believe that simply the price
of doing business with Lohan so they're
just like turn turn the other way let
her go
it's a write-off I guess get out of here
so Lohan's like you didn't see nothing
this fell off a truck
it's the Lindsay mafia apparently they
think it's not worth pursuing legally so
they're just gonna let her go Wow magic
a movie that's why movies cost 50
million dollars to make is he around or
maybe she was like one of these cats
it's like a man I'll do like I think
she's in one scene like the opening
scene or something so maybe she didn't
get much cash but she's like I want all
my wardrobe and so she ordered up a
bunch of wardrobe or maybe she got air
tight for clothing now if you're right
she does that for blow my bad
Shannen Doherty dude I'm all rats she
written into her contract that she got
to keep all her wardrobe really and
there was this one jacket that I guess
she picked out all her wardrobe I didn't
go with the when they went put together
the outfits and stuff her and the
costumer went up there's this one jacket
that she had on I was trying to get this
jacket from I was big fan of Degrassi
junior high and Degrassi high so I was
trying to get a jacket that I'd seen on
the show from Degrassi that says
Degrassi high on Degrassi junior I
thought that'd be cool
I couldn't get one in [ __ ] so I said to
the costume person I was like do me a
favor man Shannon's jacket the one she's
walking around with then in this scene
like stitch in the back two grassy high
gasps see jr. isn't homage as an omage
and I remember the Wardrobe lady was
just like are you sure you want to do
that and I was like yeah man go ahead
like it's gonna look awesome in the
movie it's a little in jokes little
shout-out to a show that I like so we go
and shoot the [ __ ] scene that day and
[ __ ]
Shannon comes smoking up to me and she
goes what the [ __ ] is de grazie hi and I
was just like Degrassi high man there's
a Canadian TV show that are actually not
oh two one oh was kind of ripped off of
she's like why is it stitched into my
jacket I was like well it's stitched
into the character's jacket she's like
Kevin I get to keep all my wardrobe and
I was like you have my stuff after we
use it first she was like can they take
this out I was like sure and then I
talked to the costume I was like can you
take it now she goes [ __ ] no that's
permanent as [ __ ] man
that's awesome
more annoying actresses in the news
Kristen Stewart is back together what
hey
wertha Twihard get the [ __ ] out I'm
kidding you can stay isn't it amazing
that some vampires just don't Sparkle I
never see the Sun you've seen what I
have I went to - Twilight premieres I
got a kid both times they took my kid
when she was way into you know don't you
have people for that you don't have to
go no that's the magic that's and now
she's like 13 and you couldn't [ __ ]
drag her there you know if I was just
like hey man let's go the [ __ ] last
while I promised I could take her yeah
totally totally you could come in place
with my kid do you hear that 13 year old
won't go to those movies anymore I'm all
over in the die oh she's passed into a
stage where she's just like you know
[ __ ] Kristen Stewart and Robert
Pattinson apparently back together again
thank God timing of this is awfully
suspicious to him how dare you sir you
think just because the movies gonna come
out in a couple months they have to get
back together again I was kind of
honestly I mean look I'm not invested in
this [ __ ] relationship and I don't
stalk and watch it like the magazines -
but I'll be honest with you it's kind of
looking forward to seeing how there
promote the movie while [ __ ] split up
yeah that would be fun to watch sources
say that our pats has put down a list of
requirements that case du has to comply
with in order to make their relationship
work now they're back together again
number one no [ __ ] in your mouth yeah
it says right here
no strange [ __ ] that's number one on the
list individual and couples counseling
that she has to pay for she must go to
mandatory individual and couples
counseling wait he sat her down he's
like you got to go to counseling you got
to pay for this is the list there's
these two both are like stinking rich
from these movies man they're quibbling
over the [ __ ] therapy but you don't
know how expensive this therapist is
he's a werewolf therapist they have to
wait like once a month when the moon
comes full and then they can only do it
wrong she has to ditch all her male
friends all of them no male friends oh
no she has to quit hanging out with all
her single girlfriends who were out on
the prowl of clubs here in Hollywood or
the [ __ ] for another she must cut
contact yeah that was a dude she must
cut contact ex-boyfriends Oh
ex-boyfriends no more ex-boyfriend
contact that's fair enough man like I
you know it's when trying to move on
with a new relationship maybe you don't
want to talk to the ex-boyfriend so much
but these two he is the ex-boyfriend so
how the [ __ ] are they gonna have a
relationship I mean other ex-boyfriends
and my favorite one the last one is she
must undergo a lie detector test
[ __ ] that's what it says
my first question is are you a shitty
actress No
those things aren't like they're not
hugging he's really admissible in court
in most cases why why the [ __ ] would
their admissible in love if you don't
trust the [ __ ] don't [ __ ] a [ __ ]
Taylor Swift is single again I'm sorry
Cade offs whittler is single again Cade
offs whittler before annexing Prussia
and Austria an invading Poland has
decided to become single that evil [ __ ]
broke up with the 18 year old high
school guys she was [ __ ] Connor
Kennedy she just wanted to be with a
Kennedy wasn't it I remember we did a
story where she went to the wedding
somebody's wedding yes she came she's 22
years old she was dating an 18 year old
Kennedy named Connor Kennedy now here's
my favorite part of the story Marilee
she wanted too much from the
relationship and he was uncomfortable
and he broke it off with her he's 18
he's [ __ ] a 22 year old yes those
Kennedys are so lucky and he's mature
enough to know that she's out of her
[ __ ] head that's what I favorite part
is he's like you know what I'm 18 but
you're [ __ ] insane so I would never
ever ever ever get back together with
you the bad news is there's a song
coming with his name on it that's gonna
embarrass that kid even weirder she
bought a mansion right next to the
Kennedy compound in Hyannis Port so he's
gonna be seeing a lot of her one way or
the other doesn't have any rabbits in TV
news Spike TV is announcing their
brand-new reality show the ten million
dollar Bigfoot bounty enough of the
pussyfooting around they are offering a
ten million dollar cash prize to anyone
who can present actual proof that
Bigfoot exists if you had a Bigfoot dips
his balls in your mouth yes you you get
the money
there will be various teams of
scientists zoologist and Bigfoot hunters
who will try to locate sasquatch and win
the 10 million
prai's in a related story Khloe
Kardashian is know where she is hiding
out in the family compound scared for
her life another lawsuit another
celebrity Megan Fox is suing all the
[ __ ] I didn't see that coming man let's
get ready to go off I'm like do you
think they'll find a bigger a bigfooter
out the only reason that the binder for
two years I'd see it coming but that
snuck up on me Megan Fox is suing a
website called celeb jihad it is a
parody website they are known as the
only celebrity gossip website run by
Islamic extremists there are fun it's a
funny website thats parody site they
posted a photo of her head on another
person's naked body to make fun of the
fact supposedly that she lost all of her
baby weight immediately upon losing the
baby that was the gist of the comedy
where were wait what
what happened did she have a baby yes
yeah okay but you just said she lost the
baby weight after losing the baby and I
was like oh I'm sorry I meant after
having the baby not after losing the
baby that wouldn't be so funny it
wouldn't be nearly as funny two very
different terms yes she lost all the
weight after having the baby later the
joke was because it's supposedly a site
run by Islamic extremists they said of
course a Muslim women have much tighter
bodies and Megan Fox Fox just hours
after giving birth this is due to the
fact that Muslim women are tilled the
fields and only take a short break to
squat behind a boulder deliver the baby
they get right back to work say it's a
spoof totally this is the photo by the
way that they put up of her this is not
Megan Fox this is another woman's body
with her head on it clearly - but which
I say good job celeb jihad she is
furious with the photo and she is suing
them to which the website responded
while we appreciate Megan Fox concern
for her image we find it hard to believe
that a woman who spent two Transformers
movies bent over with her breasts
pressed together could have her
reputation damaged by a blatantly
satirical website
for them good for them for not buckling
more news about websites and [ __ ]
Christina Aguilera's been they've got a
job offer this week she has been offered
a job to endorse a dating website for
big girls called the bacon the beautiful
calm Christina has been very vocal about
how happy she is with her new plumper
body they are offering her 3 million
dollars if she'll do a commercial for
television one for Radio 2 photo shoots
for public appearances and pays she'll
get paid three million dollars for just
that to promote the big and the
beautiful calm a plus-sized dating site
for women if she says no I'll happily do
it I'll put on a [ __ ] wig and be like
look at my tits big ladies are awesome
and the photo shoots however they asked
asked that she be poured gravy poured
over and put an apple in their mouth
ever been so much funnier if I could
have said it out loud in movie news are
you ready for a black James Bond you
think that could ever happened yes I
hope I was really hoping for black
Batman but I'll take black James Bond as
well apparently interest Elba has met
with the bond producers you should be
[ __ ] black Batman is yourself of man
he's a badass he's fantastic guy he is a
Brit he's got the accent built-in Daniel
Craig has two more movies after Scott
this is for real this isn't just like a
bond like he met with Barbara broccoli
and Michael G Wilson the producing
partners of the Bond series apparently
just two more that Daniel Craig has
signed on for it but they're already
thinking ahead and they're just having
preliminary conversations with Idris
Elba but maybe taking over bond maybe a
black bond can be amazing they'll
probably let him do one movie and then
try to replace them with some [ __ ]
robot
I say we'll see a black president before
we see a black bond oh that's a good
idea though man why not like once Daniel
Craig's done you gotta like ignite it
with some kind of interest and that
would be a way to do it too if your
watch Luther or any of the shows that
he's in a wire the brilliant actor and
he's very very talented during her bail
on the wire man Betty I'm like a monster
too big good I'm guessing oh you're just
[ __ ] taking a gun I'm hoping I thought
you had some inside info and [ __ ] the
inside track on now Hollywood dick just
hoping you know we're doing just fine
down here without the why we're talking
about movies by the way I saw some guy
fall right time here but we'll talk
about it next week but it's [ __ ]
awesome you guys are gonna love I said
good or bad it's good let's talk about
some movies that aren't good in fact
let's talk about some movies that will
suck
[Music]
oh my movie fan what's up Tom Cruise's
next film is a very adventurous very
original sci-fi adventure which he will
play a man who travels back in time to
confront the younger version of himself
you [ __ ] kidding me
it's tentatively called our name is Adam
hmm sounds super or rather looper or
Gooper not the Tom Cruise gay I'd like
to see that [ __ ] movie man the movie
works just like they send you back in
time to come in your own face don't move
[Music]
if you could go back in time I would
totally come in my own face Oh an RB
just to [ __ ] with me man just to give me
[ __ ] to talk about with my friends like
some fat stranger in a hockey jersey
broke into my room and came in my face
[Applause]
one day you're gonna understand this
little boy no but seriously if if you
had any sort of by curiosity whatsoever
yes that'd be the way to do it right go
back and suck yourself off yeah okay cuz
it's not really gay if it's you know
it's like a voucher cough it's not like
I'm jerking some other dude up it's not
really gay because it's me straight up
it's the past it's a gay pass right so
if I show up and I want to [ __ ] around
with myself I'm good right absolutely
man you take it straight in the mouth up
the ass and [ __ ] armpit and you can
let people watch man your parents could
be there anyways all that could happen
and even Jesus himself could be standing
by and he would say it's not gay it's
himself you lost me at armpit just
[Music]
thinking about what happens it's not a
stranger it's me it's the stranger
that's right yeah when you sit on your
hands oh it's Nam and then you jerk
yourself off you know like it's somebody
else I've done that yeah sure we all
have that's like but that was in a pre
fleshlight world you don't need that now
well now we can stick our dicks and
things but back then we were like I
guess if I just knock my hand out
perhaps this will feel a little
different but now it's like I'm coming
in a rubber sleeve there's a new movie
also that will suck in the works about a
an aging rock star who receives a letter
that it was meant for him by John Lennon
years after was originally sent and it
changes his life makes him want to get
back together with his 40 year old son
and perform the kind of music that he
truly wants to perform it all sounds
good I guess I mean once again here's
the premise one more time it's an aging
rock star from the 70s who's still out
there performing his hits and bangin
groupies and stuff but he's an old man
he's in his 60
now he receives a letter that he was
supposed to get when he was younger from
John Lennon who wrote him a letter it
was delivered 20 years after the fact he
gets it and it changes his life
it makes him want to perform the music
that he really feels and also
reestablish a relationship with his now
40 year old son okay it sounds like it's
a promising film maybe as an indie what
bothers me is the fact that Al Pacino is
gonna play the rock star I wonder what
that would sound like I can't I can't
take two hours of Al Pacino sing and
rock and roll on a stage with long hair
and like Derek smalls from spinal tap
mutton chops Wow I wanna rock and roll
all night party every day sympathy for
the devil Wow
look we all saw him singing and dancing
that [ __ ] cappuccino commercial Adam
Sandler movie with we don't need Adam
set we don't need Al Pacino singing or
dancing anymore
fair enough and while we're talking
about [ __ ] Adam Sandler he announced
this whole I think about [ __ ] Adam
Sandler oh no no no he announced this
week his next film is going to be a
parody of westerns specifically the
Magnificent Seven called the ridiculous
six Adam said he's gonna star in it he's
gonna produce it and he's gonna write it
he is a triple [ __ ] is what he is David
Spade will be one of the Cowboys
Evan James everybody from grownups is
going to saddle up and they're all play
cowboys I mean it's not for me but good
for him he keeps his friends close and
employed and [ __ ] like but he's [ __ ]
awful he's [ __ ] awful no one will
find that funny
he's look somebody found [ __ ]
grown-ups funny enough for them to be
like let's do it yeah let's look at the
big let's look at the big graph Oh funny
from from grown-ups - Jack and Jill
- that's my boy - ridiculous six at what
point is he just blowing guys behind a
7-eleven for being late when he makes
cop-out I always think when I think Adam
Sandler and these horrible [ __ ] films
he makes about that remember that short
segment of clips they did at the Oscars
last year where they talked about films
and what it means to you and Adam
Sandler got all high and mighty and
talked about his art when he was making
movies I'm glad you asked because I
brought it in I'm eventually trying to
one day tell the truth I don't know I'm
never gonna get there but I'm slowly
letting pieces and myself out there and
then maybe by the time I'm 85 I look
back and say alright that about summed
it up
yeah yeah you're a [ __ ] artist is
what you are you have told the truth in
your films Adam Sandler truth is you're
not [ __ ] funny that's the truth shut
up he's not [ __ ] sales right there makes
me smile matters I don't know what to
tell you all right let's get into the
geek news Kevin and I are geeks we love
the geek news
[Music]
Clark Kent quit the Daily Planet this
week I heard yeah apparently Clark Kent
was fed up with the state of German
journalism so he quit his job at the
Daily Planet
says Clark Kent Lee said I quit he
apparently is gonna start a website like
The Drudge Report or The Huffington Post
to be fair he has and in the DC Universe
before quit the Daily Planet this ain't
the first time yeah I know but this is
[ __ ] up he sees Clark Kent he's
Superman yeah just work your job
Superman look by the way Simon your
[ __ ] job your [ __ ] job is saving
the planet from aliens and [ __ ] okay
it's stopping Lex Luthor and stuff this
is just your cover this is just this is
just you with glasses on in a suit so if
being Superman is his job and being
Clark Kent is just kind of like his
off-time
get off his [ __ ] nuts let him do what
he wants the nails off time all right my
bad
another day another video game turned
into a movie Assassin's Creed has been
announced for those who play video games
the exciting news is that Michael
Fassbender has been tapped as the star
of that film that should be pretty cool
more like [ __ ] assassin's cleave man
because got that [ __ ] flesh cleaver
between Liam Neeson is huge Michael
Fassbender si shame it's now available
like everywhere man poppin it you know
what watch the first five minutes ladies
you ain't gonna get past the first five
minutes cuz as soon as he walks out you
see it [ __ ] his fast bender dangling
in [ __ ] you just gonna be like
[Music]
faster-faster-faster
[Music]
[Laughter]
see what you've done that's the one
that's underwater there's a new
Kickstarter campaign to help drive the
development of the movie based on the
comic book The Goon which has been going
around for a while Eric Powell the
creator of the comic book it's a great
comic by the way if you haven't read it
it's just hilarious and really clever
he's been work with David Fincher
legendary movie director David Fincher
trying to develop this and they've got
it all together Paul Giamatti has agreed
to play Frankie in the thing Clancy
Brown is gonna voice the goon they're
just trying to make it happen but they
can't get a greenlit because no studio
will greenlight a pg-13 animated film it
has to be for kids or else they won't
make it so they started a Kickstarter
campaign to raise enough money to do a
feature-length what they call a story
reel which is basically storyboard
strung together with voices and sound
effects to give the studio's an idea of
what this actually will turn out to be
at the end the reason I caught on to it
because someone's in the video that
they're using to try to raise money for
the Kickstarter campaign and it's
awesome if you're a gutten fan here's a
little taste of those guys playing those
characters from the Kickstarter campaign
that's the Ironman trailer or we have a
sequence here we go
step right up and become a part of movie
history we're sending goon a Hollywood
and we'd like to keep his clothes
[Music]
congratulations you just became an
executive producer good step oh you got
a little tease there the Iron Man
trailer came out this week [ __ ] it
sure did they came out and I came all
over man it was its phenom I watched 18
times on day one so good 18 in a row man
so [ __ ] good for one of spoilers we
haven't seen it when the [ __ ] mansion
goes down the hill and Kingsley has the
Mandarin for the person hearing his
voice I thought it was cool like he
chose a cool voice for it you know like
not an obvious choice or something is
done like take your ear oh yeah I would
have made how many rings on my finger oh
I am entering it's a Mandarin dude in a
Mickey Rooney here's a little taste of
the Iron Man 3 trailer if you missed it
this week by the way 11 million hits on
the very first day it came out
most of those were conserved we had over
and over it is not just Robert Downey
jr. coming back and everybody who's
involved with the previous two this time
around Jon Favreau is not directing but
it's directed by Shane black guy that
wrote the lethal weapons and I don't
know if you saw Kiss Kiss Bang Bang but
that was a phenomenal [ __ ] if you
haven't seen Kiss Kiss Bang Bang man go
check it out tonight or this weekend
it's Robert Downey jr. and Val Kilmer
lizard named Michelle Monaghan I think
is the actress phenomenally funny
[ __ ] la detective story that's like
just Robert Downey jr. as a charm
factory so anyway I guess he brought the
Shane black into Iron Man 3 and the
trailers just [ __ ] phenomenal a lot
of people were speculating whether he
could handle something of this scope and
size but it looks like the trailers all
picked yeah here's a little piece of the
trailer from Iron Man 3
[Music]
ladies children
[Music]
some people call me a terrorist
I consider myself to teacher
lesson number one heroes there is no
such thing
[Music]
[Music]
come on right doesn't have a real like
Empire Strikes Back vibe about it like
really like there's some [ __ ] some
stakes and whatnot I'd make a prediction
I don't think Pepper Potts comes out of
it alive really oh [ __ ] yeah that's a
vibe I get off it finally another movie
that kills up gwyneth watch that [ __ ]
virus movie over and over again just to
watch just to watch your [ __ ] Total
Recall out and just disappear I'm ready
for Matt Damon yeah thank you [ __ ]
dies on you I'm always [ __ ] up in as
much as like she does spoilers if you
haven't seen what's a contagion yeah she
dies early in the mood
gets sick and dies early in the movie
yeah but you find out she cheated on
Matt Damon I know who the [ __ ] she's on
Matt Damon man me right what Ben Affleck
that movie but a lot more interesting if
Ben Affleck was Matt Damon's husband
yeah he dies in the beginning you find
out who's cheating with Gwyneth Paltrow
that's right
and Matt's gonna raise his child by
himself with George Carlin as his dad
we always like to say goodnight by
asking a very famous musical question by
now based on Kevin's obsession with a
certain Irish actors penis Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] of course you can go to Neeson [ __ ]
calm dad your own fact about the size of
Liam's [ __ ]
somebody on Twitter last week was like
you guys got to stop doing this bit it's
getting old
I say horseshit man this is my - oh
that's you this is a victory lap for the
show by the time we get here we're like
ah we put it into [ __ ] second gear
and cruise and people keep writing funny
stuff do they keep writing a row keep
reading it here is the the week's top
facts about the size of Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that
when God has sex he yells Oh Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big when he makes snow angels it looks
like the angel is sitting on top of the
Rockefeller Center Christmas tree him
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it refused Vito
Corleone's offer Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big
that one way or another it's going to
find you it's going to get you get you
get you get you Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big we had to outsource its cleaning
operations to Bangladesh that's a shame
to lose us jobs for that Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big they have worked out of
Vegas act where Liam drinks water and
his [ __ ] sings Bluemoon ventriloquist's
very big in Vegas Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big detectives have found the remains
of Jimmy Hoffa Amelia Earhart and Cuba
Gooding jr. career hidden in his urethra
poor Cuba is so [ __ ] mean he did that
gay boat movies all defense my point
show me the money indeed Cuba Gooding
jr. Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big any
naked photo of him just looks like the
photographer had their finger over the
lens and lastly Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big and for Halloween he's painting it
green so that it can go to a party as
the Loch Ness monster eating a
watermelon ladies and gentlemen thank
you so very much for making your way out
here and joining us tonight
thank you for selling us out again if
you want to stick around at 10 o'clock
Ralph Garman is gonna read comic books
man we do Hollywood babble-on comic-con
theater coming up next to 10 o'clock
it's a good time he literally reads
every voice in the book as a different
character and stuff we've done two times
before we're gonna do it for the third
and final time for the Batman story
cacophony that I wrote happening right
now after we cleared a place now look
you don't have a watch there stop
looking I do I'm just so used to doing
that she's such an old habit to break
and I also do this a lot
that's another old habit but anyway if
you want to stick around watch that show
that's the ten o'clock talk but if you
don't man I can't thank you enough for
coming out tonight it was a great
feeling when we could be home see a
bunch of people man a wall of humanity
and Hollywood battle on and that is
Hollywood babble-on for this week I'm
Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman all right
ladies and gentlemen give it up one more
time for Kevin Smith and the ralph 1 &
Hollywood babble-on live at the Lovitz
[Music]